monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues nous avons le plaisir
aujourd'hui de recevoir Monsieur Niel
fondateur actionnaire principal du
groupe Iliad s'il devait on devait
apporter des précisions groupe français
de télécommunications qui est notamment
la maison mère de Free opérateur de
téléphonie mobile et fournisseurs
d'accès Internet que nous connaissons
évidemment toutes et tous et que vous
présentez encore aujourd'hui comme étant
qui est présenté encore aujourd'hui
comme étant le troubillon des télécoms
européens inventeur du concept hier de
la box internet aujourd'hui promoteur
d'une plus grande force d'une plus forte
concurrence par les prix et demain
peut-être futur concurrent français des
gafams américaines le groupe que vous
avez fondé monsieur Niel poursuit sa
croissance sa diversification vous nous
en parlerez tant en surface de salariés
16500 me dit-on un chiffre d'affaires
qui atteint plus de 7 milliards me
dit-on également en 2021 45 millions
d'abonnés en Europe 21 millions en
France 14 millions en Pologne 9 millions
en Italie favoriser un peu la
présentation de vos performances
l'internationalisation de votre groupe
qui réalise désormais plus d'un tiers de
son chiffre d'affaires en dehors de la
France accélère fortement et nous
questionne sur l'opportunité d'une plus
grande concentration des opérateurs de
télécommunications au niveau européen
après avoir acquis salt dont on nous
parlions il y a quelques instants
opérateur Suisse UPC Pologne opérateur
polonais évidemment vous avez récemment
augmenté votre participation au capital
d'un opérateur luxembourgeois et d'un
opérateur britannique pour pas le nommer
Vodafone au regard de ces évolutions
récentes quelle ambition européenne
portez-vous pour le groupe Iliad free
quels sont les perspectives de
développement dans les prochaines années
faut-il y voir la préparation d'un
retrait progressif du marché français
alors que la France est aujourd'hui le
pays le plus fibré d'Europe et que le
chantier de la fibre optique ne fait que
commencer chez nos voisins européens si
nous sommes évidemment très heureux de
voir que l'expertise française en
matière de fibre optique s'exporte hors
de France nous constatons en France dans
nos départements que les mécontentement
des abonnés des élus des collectivités
sont de plus en plus nombreux et
évidemment dans cette assemblée des
collectivités territoriales vous aurez
probablement beaucoup de questions sur
ce sujet lors de son audition devant
notre commission en janvier dernier la
présidente de larsep a annoncé la
notification par Free d'un plan de
reprise de certains de ces réseaux de
fibres optiques notamment en région
parisienne pour lesquelles des incidents
des malfaçons ont été observés
pourriez-vous nous donner davantage de
détails si vous pouvez sur ce plan de
reprise son financement et son
calendrier combien de lignes combien
d'abonnés combien de collectivités
seraient concernées l'état de la
concurrence et de la régulation dans le
secteur des télécoms retient aujourd'hui
bien sûr notre attention celle de notre
collègue Patrick chaise en tout premier
lieu
particulier au regard des contentieux
juridique en cours entre Orange et la
recette ces opérateurs historiques plaid
pour une hausse des tarifs de découpage
conteste le pouvoir de sanctions de la
recette alors même jusqu'à introduire
une QPC à ce sujet dénonce un transfert
de valeur et les opérateurs commerciaux
ces derniers refusent donc vous toutes
hausse du tarif de dégroupage Bouygues
ayant même porté plainte contre Orange
pour défaut d'entretien du réseau cuivre
monsieur le Président qu'elle regarde
portez-vous sur cette situation les
contrôles exercés par l'arccepte
l'Autorité de la concurrence vous
semble-t-elle suffisant pour assurer un
juste niveau de régulation de régulation
pardon sans favoriser un opérateur
plutôt qu'un autre quel serait les
conséquences d'une hausse des tarifs de
découpage pour fruits en particulier une
hausse de ces tarifs conduirait-elle
free à revenir sur son engagement de
limiter la hausse de ses abonnements
téléphoniques dans un contexte où
l'inflation pourrait atteindre jusqu'à
7% de cette année où j'ai appris hier
que je pense de téléphonie représente
aujourd'hui le quatrième poste de
dépense des ménages français il est
indéniable que l'arrivée de Free sur le
marché français a permis une baisse
massive et générale des prix des
abonnements il semble que nous
assistions à un retour de balancier si
la France demeure le pays d'Europe ou
les prix de la téléphonie mobile sont en
moyenne les plus bas une hausse même de
quelques euros serait difficile à
comprendre notamment parce que la
qualité du déploiement n'est plus au
rendez-vous ainsi parmi les sujets
majeurs d'incompréhension des
particuliers des élus et des
collectivités il y a notamment celui des
modalités d'implantation des antennes
sujets très difficiles qui c'est
fortement accéléré qu'on sait
qu'effectivement à l'amélioration de la
couverture numérique de nos territoires
nous le constatons tous l'impression est
plutôt celle d'un déploiement précipité
sans concertation notamment avec les
élus locaux bien souvent voilà donc je
serai heureuse de vous entendre là
dessus et avant de mes collègues posées
les questions voilà mes premières
questions je vais vous laisser monsieur
le Président prendre la parole pour un
propos liminaire et ensuite je donnerai
la parole bien sûr à Patrick chaise et
ensuite à l'ensemble des de mes
collègues qui se signaleront sur notre
boucle voilà merci c'est le président
merci madame la Présidente merci de
m'accueillir ce matin je vais faire il y
a un propos introductif plutôt sur la
France mais on pourra parler de du du
généralement du reste si vous le
souhaitez moi ce que je constate
nous sommes le nous sommes le meilleur
exemple de ce que la concurrence dans
les télécoms
peut permettre de créer elle a apporté
de de l'innovation des bas prix et
beaucoup d'investissement dans les
raisons en France on s'est développé sur
un mode d'elle vertueux dans les
télécoms avec une régulation qui a été
extrêmement volontariste notamment durée
régulateur sectoriel et de l'Autorité de
la concurrence qui a permis de
[Musique]
décidé d'aller ailleurs pour que
l'ensemble des Français puissent
bénéficier de cette concurrence c'est ce
que nous avons fait comme quand nous
sommes allés à la Réunion et à Mayotte
il s'est passé un truc incroyable on est
arrivé Free est arrivé à la Réunion et à
Mayotte les prix se sont écroulés
principalement la réunion les prix ont
été divisés par deux dans le même temps
dans les Antilles c'était pas le cas les
prix restaient très hauts nous venons de
d'ouvrir nous venons de nous lancer en
retard dans les Antilles et de la même
manière le l'impact sur les prix est
significatif et l'idée c'était de rendre
à tous les Français le bénéfice d'une
concurrence effective
et réelle donc aujourd'hui grâce à ça
grâce à ses investissements nous sommes
devenus le Iliade est devenu le sixième
opérateur panéen on vous l'avait rappelé
on a un peu plus de 42 millions
d'abonnés en Europe et on réalise en
2022 8 millions d'euros de
8 millions d'euros un peu plus pardon 8
milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en France nous avons 14
millions d'abonnés mobiles et 7 millions
d'abonnés 7,2 millions d'abonnés fixes
de foyer fixes de foyer à qui nous
délivrons un service fixe en fibre
optique et en ADSL nous sommes le
deuxième employeur du secteur derrière
orange avec plus de 10000 salariés
directs en France et puis nous sommes
probablement une des sociétés où la
société qui est en France investi le
plus nous investissons environ 25% de
nos chiffres d'affaires annuel dans nos
réseaux
on était monté jusqu'à 30% d'arbraissait
un peu à 25% mais ce qui donne des
chiffres
très très élevés pour une société qu'on
peut qualifier de mature puisque notre
croissance aujourd'hui et de l'ordre
d'une petite dizaine de pour cent chaque
année donc on investit lourdement c'est
les investissements qui sont faits dans
nos réseaux on a une stratégie en France
que vous connaissez avec freak et
extrêmement simple on est l'opérateur
fixés mobile on propose des offres
simples et attractives on ne perd nos
réseaux on est né comme tous les autres
opérateurs de la possibilité d'utiliser
le réseau notamment d'orange c'est à
dire de pratiquer le dégroupage et nous
avons migré vers une activité dans
lequel nous déployons nos propres
réseaux en fibres optique et nous avons
nos propres sites mobiles on a plus de
23000 sites mobiles
en France donc des offres on est
opérateur fixés mobile des offres
simples et attractives déployées
exploiter nos propres réseaux et dans le
même temps diminuer être capable avancer
pour diminuer notre empreinte
Henri environnementale donc si je
reviens à la France je crois qu'on peut
se réjouir d'une couverture très haut
très haut débit fixe et mobile élevé on
est devenu vous le savez le je crois le
pays la France en tout cas dans les
grands pays le plus le celui qui est le
plus couvert en termes de
de foyers où on peut s'abonner à la
fibre optique on a eu un engagement fort
des opérateurs alternatifs il supporte
une grande partie des investissements si
on prend le FTTH 60% des investissements
dans le FTTH sont faits par les trois
opérateurs alternatifs en conservant 40%
mais c'est une part qui continue à
diminuer donc c'est investissement c'est
un investissement lourd parfois on a le
sentiment quand on rencontre des sur le
terrain des des
politiques ou même des entreprises que
la totalité de ces investissements sont
faits pour enregistes sont faits de fait
de manière minoritaire au total par
Orange majoritairement par les
opérateurs alternatifs nouvel entrantes
sur ces sujets et puis il y a un élément
qui est extrêmement important c'est que
la réalité de la concurrence qui existe
en France fait que nous bénissions vous
l'avez rappelé madame la présidente des
tarifs
les plus bas ou parmi les plus bas en
fonction de des cas
en
Europe
et si on le ramène au pouvoir d'achat
dans le monde à pouvoir d'achat
équivalent le les États-Unis pratique
des prix 3 à 4 fois plus cher au prix
français donc on a un bilan je pense
d'ouverture à la concurrence 25 ans
après c'était 80 1998 et nous étions la
dès 1998 qui est donc très je pense très
positif alors on a des sujets vous les
avez rappelés des problèmes
collectivement ou des sujets
collectivement à traiter je vais on va
je vais vous en citer quelques
quelques-uns mais on pourra les
reprendre en détail plus tard mais il
reste beaucoup d'investissements à
réaliser la complétude FTH
comment on arrive à couvrir le
la totalité des foyers on en parle
également il y a quelques instants comme
on arrive à couvrir la totalité des
foyers en termes de fibre optique
comment
on est capable de faire des
raccordements finaux couteux complexes
comment on améliore notre notre
couverture mobile et vous l'avez rappelé
avec une forme de de de d'ambivalence ou
en fait on nous dit il faut le meilleur
couverture mais dans le même temps il
faut moins d'antenne c'est pas facile le
déploiement des nouvelles technologies
5g
et puis un sujet de résilience des
réseaux je sais pas si vous souhaiterez
l'évoquer aujourd'hui mais qui a un
sujet important on a des problèmes sur
les conditions envisagées pour l'arrêt
du cuivre qui ne sont pas satisfaisantes
et dans lequel le calendrier est trop
étendu et puis c'est on est dans un
contexte difficile pour les opérateurs
puisqu'on a de l'inflation une hausse
significative des coûts de l'énergie on
est en France pas les plus mal le team
mais c'est quand même un sujet
significatif sur nos bilans des taux
d'intérêt qui montent et nous sommes
tous des opérateurs
endettés parce que les demandes de
déploiement de réseau nous ont été
faites ont été mises en œuvre mais elles
l'ont été faites notamment parce que la
totalité des opérateurs de
télécommunication française ont vendu
des actifs pour financer c'est très
lourde investissements notamment dans la
fibre donc on a tous vendu nos antennes
pour récupérer du cash et investir se
cache dans le déploiement de la fibre
optique
à côté de ça on a besoin d'une stabilité
d'un cas de concurrentiel
équitable et pour cela j'aimerais vous
parler de trois points précisément le
premier point qui est l'arrêt du cuivre
on l'a évoqué la fiscalité et l'effer
mobile et la couverture des zones
blanches et grises en mobile alors la
règle du cuivre c'est pour nous un
problème important ce qui je pense qu'il
faut se mettre à la place du de
l'utilisateur quand on déploigne une
zone en fibre optique
globalement on va dire 80% des 475 80%
des personnes qui sont dans cette zone
en fibre optique vont prendre sur
quelques années le un abonnement la
fibre optique spontanément ça ça va être
quelque chose d'extrêmement facile
simple ils vont avoir l'intérêt quand
ils vont déménager mon pauvre demander
de l'ADSL naturellement ils vont prendre
de la fibre et c'est quelque chose
d'accepter on a une dizaine de % des
foyers dans lesquels il va falloir
travailler et expliquer et on va réussir
à les convaincre et puis on a les
irréductibles qui représentent en
fonction des zones 10 à 15 % des foyers
et saisir réductibles
c'est pas qu'ils aiment la DSL c'est que
ça marche ils ne veulent pas que ça
bouge il faut que ça soit stabilisé et
le seul moyen le seul élément qui va
permettre de les faire basculer c'est
l'extinction du cuivre on l'a vu à les
vis un nom la vue à certains endroits où
on a fait des expérimentations les seuls
moments où cela fonctionne c'est quand
on dit voilà demain il n'y a plus de
cuivre il va falloir basculer à la fibre
optique et c'est le seul moment dans
lequel
ça marche et je pense que collectivement
doit avoir un but c'est d'éteindre le
plus rapidement possible ce réseau
en cuivre déjà parce que ça va réduire
l'impact environnemental puisque avoir
deux raisons en parallèle ça n'a pas
environnemental double voire même un peu
plus puisque le CUV est extrêmement
consommateur
d'énergie et puis ça veut dire aussi
optimiser l'investissement puisque quand
on a déployé ces réseaux de fibres
optique plus ils sont pleins plus ils
sont remplis plus notre investissement
est rentaliser et rentabiliser pardon
alors on trouve que Orange propose un
plan peu ambitieux
avec des fermetures techniques en volume
qui commence longtemps après la
fermeture commerciale c'est-à-dire qu'on
va continuer de vendre des accès mais on
va continuer en plus de les laisser
vivre
à la vitesse proposée par Orange
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il restera je
peux me tromper mais environ la moitié
des lignes en France de de
la moitié des lignes en cuivre en France
qui sont toujours en exploitation qui ou
à des zones on pourra toujours avoir du
cuivre et c'est vraiment un sujet pour
nous parce qu'on ne comprend pas
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui nous empêche
rapidement d'éteindre des grandes villes
on l'a pratiqué des expérimentations
dans des villes moyennes dans des
petites villes ça marche très très bien
et en fait
aujourd'hui ce qui est proposé
c'est de déréguler orange sur des zones
fibrées sans pousser une extinction
rapide du cuivre et on pense que c'est
une erreur
c'est une erreur générale globale c'est
une erreur pour la France c'est une
erreur pour le pays de laisser 5 ans
entre un moment où on dit on va fermer
une zone et la fermer réellement puisque
c'est 50 n'ont rien apporté de de
pressing vont rien apporter plus ils ne
vont pas permettre de se basculement qui
doit être rapide et dans le même temps
nous dit bah sur ces zones on va
fortement augmenter le tarif du
dégroupage pour aider pour subventionner
d'une certaine manière orange mais si
Orange a un problème dans ces zones
qu'ils éteignent le cuivre qu'il ferme
le cuivre que collectivement nous
poussions ces foyers à passer vers
la fibre optique puisque une fermeture
dire on va fermer dans cinq ans ça amène
le sujet de migration dans 5 ans vous
allez pas pousser des gens qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas envie de migrer
vers la fibre optiques à migrer plus
rapidement si ce réseau si le réseau en
cuivre ne ferme que dans 5 ans et donc
on pense que cette proposition est
critiquables rien ne justifie
d'augmenter le tarif du dégroupage quand
le cuivre n'est pas réellement arrêté
c'est une formidable ronde de situation
pour Orange avec une technologie
obsolète et je vous l'ai dit
précédemment des abonnés qui sont
coincés sur cette technologie parce
qu'ils n'ont pas envie de changer on les
a vu on est tenté les combats on n'a pas
compris ils n'ont ils ne le souhaite pas
et donc tant qu'on ne va pas contraindre
cette migration on y arrivera pas la
fermeture
commerciale je vous l'ai dit
précédemment là aucune aucun impact sur
la migration c'est ses abonnés de ses
clients ils ne vont pas migrer vers le
réseau de fibre optique si on est à une
date lointaine de fermeture de cette
réseau et
si Orange reçoit plus de recettes pour
le cuivre en plus je pense qu'on motive
pas orange à fermer ces réseaux ce qu'il
faut voir c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
opérateurs natifs migra plus vite les
abonnés de la fibre optique vers la
fibre optique du DSL va à la fibre
optique orange est-ce qu'il faut voir un
autre élément qui est extrêmement
important aujourd'hui la DSL chez Orange
est vendu 10 euros moins cher que la
fibre optique donc on a un intérêt
aujourd'hui financier chez Orange vous
allez chez Sosh vous regardez la DSL est
vendue 10 euros moins cher que la fibre
optique donc tous ces éléments là nous
laisse penser que
que
permettent une dérégulation une
dérégulation sur ces zones est une
erreur qui à partir de ce monde-là
l'ARCEP perdra tout levier d'action sur
Orange
qui au bout pourrait même décider de
convaincre de garder le cuivre encore
plus longtemps voire de continuer
d'augmenter les tarifs
et de conserver de faire un monopole à
Orange sur ces réseaux et sur ces zones
il y a un autre élément qui me paraît
extrêmement important aucun pays
d'Europe n'a augmenté ses tarifs du
dégroupage et la recommandation de l'UE
est une stabilité des prix du dégroupage
donc en plus on ferait un chemin on aura
été très en avance sur le dégroupage et
on terminerait toutes ces étapes de
dégroupage du cuivre en qui a été une
énorme réussite ce qui a permis
l'émergence d'une concurrence
importante qui a permis de la création
des acteurs jouent des acteurs je vous
l'ai dit précédemment mais on se
retrouverait dans ce cadre là avec
exactement la fin une fin qui serait une
fin
franchement pas belle c'est à dire de
mal terminé une séquence qui a été bien
nous notre vision elle est simple la
réductive elle est importante il faut
l'accélérer
s'il y a une hausse du dégroupage tu
arrives de dégroupage ça doit être un an
avant la fermeture réelle la fermeture
technique de ses réseaux pour accélérer
pour inciter à accélérer la migration de
ces abonnés
récalcitrant
la hausse du découpage de la servir qui
augmente la rente d'orange nous avons
été étonné d'ailleurs d'entendre la
directrice générale d'orange parlait
d'un deal avec la recette et annoncé
qu'une augmentation du tarif de
découpage est acquise en 2024 avant même
qu'il y ait une analyse de marché donc
si maintenant il y a des deals c'est un
peu particulier c'est à la mode sûrement
mais bon on a le droit d'espérer dans
les télécoms d'avoir une forme de
concurrence un peu un peu un peu
différente et
donc on vous le redit on doit penser que
la dérégulation de dos intervenir quand
on a une date rapide d'extin
d'extinction
du cuivre et puis à côté de ça on a
besoin d'un accompagnement on a besoin
d'explications sur cette fermeture du
cuivre pour rassurer les populations la
bien fait avec l'émergence de la TNT on
pense qu'on doit faire un grand plan de
la même
manière et expliquer que le cul vénère
était que pour ceux qui bien évidemment
ne peuvent
que pour ceux qui peuvent accéder à la
fibre optique c'est vraiment on pense
que c'est vraiment un sujet
incroyablement important une dérivée de
la science trop rapide et mal encadrée
peut venir bouleverser le secteur et
pour nous c'est notre principal point
d'inquiétude aujourd'hui en France il y
a un autre sujet qui me tient à coeur
qui est la fiscalité alors la fiscalité
sectoriale
c'est un véritable fardeau on est je
pense avec l'énergie le secteur le plus
surtaxé de ce pays et on a
une taxe spécifique une des taxes
spécifiques que l'on a dans ce secteur
qui est différemobile qui est
insupportable et injuste alors on est
les spécialistes
en France pour taxer les télécoms alors
c'est en général avec une bonne raison
je me souviens moi de la TS CNC c'est
une taxe en contrepartie d'une TVA
à 5,5 que nous avait pardon qu'une TVA
disposions à 5,5 quand nous vendu en nos
abonnements de télévision on nous a dit
vous avez une TV à réduite vous allez
nous financer le CNC ça a bien se lancer
on va vous mettre une tstd la taxe tstt
pour le CNC la TVA est revenue sur les
abonnements de télévision à 20% deviner
on a toujours cette taxe
on nous avait mis une taxe affectée
Infinity j'ai oublié le terme
infinitisé mal pour compenser l'arrêt de
la publicité sur FTV maintenant la taxe
ça va plus pour France Télévision elle
va au budget général et le
libelyper mobile qui devait compenser la
perte de la taxe professionnelle c'était
pour le secteur sans 120 millions en 20
en 2022 on est à 270 millions et on sera
à 500 millions d'euros de taxes en 2027
alors cette taxe elle est injuste elle
est basée sur le nombre de fréquences
que nous émettons et sur le nombre de
d'antenne et donc bien évidemment plus
on nous demande de déployer nos réseaux
plus ces taxe augmente plus on nous
demande d'avoir de la capacité de la
rapidité plus de fréquence déployée une
meilleure couverture plus cette taxe
augmente on nous promet une réforme tous
les ans depuis je sais plus combien
d'années trois ans il faut savoir pas
beaucoup mais on nous promet
régulièrement une réforme de cette taxe
qui ne vient pas et dans le même temps
on augmente cette cette taxe augmente
sur le
secteur et nous sommes en fait un peu
les otages on a l'impression de la
relation entre l'État et les
collectivités
la taxifer elle est inéquitable parce
que parallèlement à ça elle n'est pas
basée sur elle elle ne s'applique pas de
la même manière à tous les opérateurs
deux opérateurs mutualisent leurs
réseaux ces Bouygues et SFR ils font du
rat de Cherry alors ça pose en par
ailleurs un certain nombre de problèmes
parce que quand le réseau on l'a vu la
semaine dernière quand le réseau de l'un
le réseau de l'autre et en panne donc on
perd 50% des des capacités sur des zones
mais on la puisqu'il partage leur réseau
ils partagent exactement ces taxe donc
la manière dont les mises en oeuvre
cette taxe c'est qu'elle est calculée
pose des sujets qui ne sont pas
réplicables pour orangerie donc Orange
et Free paye une surtax parallèlement à
ça orange j'ai pris son punis puisque ce
sont les deux acteurs qui n'ont pas le
droit d'utiliser du Huawei en France oui
SFR ont le droit de en utiliser ce qui a
un impact pour nous puisque les
équipements de Huawei consomment 3 pour
30% d'énergie en moins que les
équipements que nous avons le droit
d'utiliser donc si vous ramenez pardon à
des chiffres concrets aujourd'hui
il paye deux fois plus diffère que SFR
ou Bouygues Telecom ramener à notre
chiffre d'affaires et en 2027 ça sera
trois fois plus
donc on pense que c'est c'est un sujet
important pour nous sur lequel nous
militons pour avoir quelque chose de
plus juste soit un plafonnement de cet
axe qui nous permette en toute
tranquillité d'augmenter nos couvertures
et encore une fois quand vous nous dites
venez découvrir nos territoires on se
dit ok mais au-delà de cette couverture
et des antennes qu'on va déployer on
peut avoir un supplément de taxe à payer
donc
on pense que soit un plafonnement soit
une taxe sur le chiffre d'affaires je
sais tout ce qu'on déteste mais ce
serait des éléments qui nous paraissent
plus juste et une taxe sur le chiffre
d'affaires plus un plafonnement me
paraîtrait
la disparition de l'attaque me
paraîtrait le nirvana en toute franchise
une amélioration ou au moins quelque
chose de plus juste de
juste répartis entre les différents
opérateurs et puis il y a un troisième
sujet que j'aimerais évoquer avec vous
et qui indirectement lié qui est la
couverture mobile vous vous souvenez de
nous avions eu un New Deal sur lequel
nous étions engagés collectivement nous
opérateurs à rajouter 5000 sites 13
aujourd'hui sont en
service les autres sont en cours de
construction les 800 derniers de ces
5000 ayant été affectés en 2023 on pense
qu'il serait intelligent de d'éviter un
point de coupure quand ces 5000 sites
seront allumés et de penser ou de mettre
en oeuvre un New Deal
2 parce que bien évidemment au boulot de
ces 5000 sites allumés vous aurez des
demandes supplémentaires de de
couverture c'est quelque chose que nous
opérateur on aime parce que c'est de la
prévisibilité une vision long terme ça
évite en 2030 de d'avoir des discussions
longues sur le renouvellement des
fréquences
pour les
pour les opérateurs et donc on pense que
les pouvoirs publics devraient profiter
de cette opportunité dès maintenant pour
regarder comment on est capable
d'avancer et de définir un volume de
couverture de zone de citadine déployer
en zone blanche et en zone grise on
pense que cela ne pourrait avoir que des
effets positifs sinon 2027 on va se
retrouver avec ces 5000 sites déployés
et en fait toujours des ongles blanches
et des eaux de grises où vous pourriez
avoir
des demandes
depuis 10 ans d'une manière plus plus
conclusive depuis 10 ans nos
investissements sont plus haut je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure on est monté
jusqu'à 30% de notre chiffre d'affaires
l'année dernière on était à 25 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires pour assumer
des obligations de couverture fibre et
mobiles qui sont découvertes des
demandes de couverture forte et étendues
on a ce problème de surfiscalité
et vous aviez dit tout à l'heure comment
on est capable de concurrencer les gafam
mais c'est en ayant des des moyens la
quasi-totalité du cash produit par les
télécoms aujourd'hui les parts orange
les opérateurs alternatifs depuis des
années non pas de génération de cash
faux positif parce que les alternatives
investissent lourdement dans leur réseau
avec des fréquences qui dans le même
temps sont vendus toujours plus cher
et je vous l'ai dit nous avons vendu
énormément de nos actifs de nos pylônes
pour permettre de financer ça malgré
tout il nous reste beaucoup de travail à
me faire et à mettre en oeuvre pour
continuer de déployer ce réseau et dans
le même temps là où nous sommes donc des
opérateurs avec des bilans tendus on
nous parle d'augmenter les tarifs des
découpages de complétude des réseaux
fibres de résilience des réseaux et puis
j'oublie toutes les autres idées que
certains d'entre vous mais c'est pas au
Sénat je le sais c'est sûrement ailleurs
que ça doit exister mais toutes les
idées c'est vrai toutes les idées que
vous pourriez avoir potentiellement pour
taxer les opérateurs et ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que l'argent l'argent que
nous avons le cash que nous arrivons à
générer nous sommes des sociétés je
crois dans leur grande majorité
responsables nous l'utilisons pour
réinvestir pour se développer à
l'international pour aller créer des
choses qui vont permettre de
concurrencer les Gafa et je pense qu'à
un moment où les pouvoirs publics
réclament de la réindustrialisation de
l'indépendance nationale de la présence
française dans les domaines stratégiques
et dans l'intelligence artificielle dans
la cybersécurité c'est pas très heureux
dans le même temps d'approuvrir les
groupes les mieux à même de défendre sur
ces sujets nos couleurs voilà je de
manière excusez moi pour ce cette
introduction peut-être un peu longue
mais on est prêt à répondre à la je suis
prêt pardon de répondre à la totalité de
vos questions
aussi beaucoup Monsieur Niels je vais
passer la parole à Patrick chaise qui
est donc le président du groupe
numérique Anne-Catherine parce qu'elle
est rapporteur budgétaires et ensuite à
l'ensemble de mes collègues Patrick
merci la présidente monsieur le
Président merci pour vos limitaire je
dirais en introduction que je suis un
peu resté sur ma faim parce que vous
avez fait effectivement un constat
beaucoup de constats j'ai pas entendu
beaucoup de propositions et je vais
essayer par mes questions de vous
inciter à nous faire des propositions
assez concrètes alors plusieurs sujets
déjà le sujet de la fermeture du cuivre
vous avez effectivement exprimé que le
plan présenté par Orange n'était pas
ambitieux je peux le partager je peux
effectivement donc aller dans ce sens
pour faire en sorte que on accélère et
que on puisse être aussi assez
intelligent dans la mise en oeuvre de
cette fermeture de plans néanmoins mais
quelle mesure proposez-vous
de façon concrète pour faire en sorte
que la migration et notamment tous les
travaux induits sur les parties
privatives puissent faire dans les
bonnes conditions
le dégroupage je m'excuse mais là je
vous suis pas du tout dans le
raisonnement et je vous suis pas depuis
longtemps parce qu'en fait en 2016 dans
le cadre de la loi Macron j'avais déposé
un amendement qui s'appelait un
amendement zone fibrée et qui faisait
que l'idée
permettait de déréguler le prix du
cuivre pour faire en sorte justement que
le prix du cuivre monte et que
mécaniquement et bien donc ce prix du
cuivre montant le prix donc de
l'abonnement cuivre étant plus haut que
le prix de la fibre on est un
basculement naturel du cuivre vers la
fibre je ne comprends pas pourquoi ce
mécanisme vous gêne et pourquoi donc on
ne peut pas donc aujourd'hui le mettre
en oeuvre
sur l'hiver alors solifaire par contre
je suis à 100% avec vous ça fait cinq
ans que j'ai pose un amendement tous les
ans dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finance pour faire en sorte que cette
impôt injuste soit corrigée et puisse
être
remodelés de façon à ce qu'il soit plus
égalitaire sur l'ensemble des opérateurs
avec d'ailleurs des possibilités de de
redirection peut-être d'une partie de
cette de cette impôt mais je reviendrai
juste après sur le New Deal je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec vous le New Deal
c'est pas les 5000 sites ciblés le New
Deal c'est un objectif partagé entre
l'État l'ARCEP et les opérateurs pour
faire en sorte que à échéance
qui est pas encore atteinte l'ensemble
des habitations de notre pays soient
couverts par les quatre opérateurs
certes avec un mécanisme de couverture
ciblée mais pas que avec aussi les
investissements des opérateurs les
investissements propres et cet
objectif-là il a été financé
le collectif puisque on a donc vous
l'avez dit fait en sorte que les
licences soient donc prorogées et c'est
un coût estimé à 3 et 5 milliards c'est
à dire que collectivement on a mis 3 à 5
milliards sur la table pour faire pour
permettre aux opérateurs d'atteindre cet
objectif et pour ma part je suis
absolument contre mais plus que contre
un New Deal ça me paraît être vraiment
de la malhonnêteté je vous le dis de
façon très claire
pour le reste je veux dire je comprends
pas d'ailleurs et vous allez me
l'expliquer que vous avez une politique
tarifaire agressive qui donc annonce une
stabilité de vos tarifs sur les années
qui viennent bon la question c'est
estonable et est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
allez pouvoir tenir votre engagement
enfin réponse que vous n'avez pas donné
à la présidente me permet de reposer la
question c'est sur le plan de reprise au
niveau de
des
réseaux qui ont été
identifiés et enfin
je conclu par cela même la présidente
aujourd'hui finalement quand on fait
l'état des lieux du numérique fixe et
mobile on se rend compte que il y a tout
un tas de points ou de briques qui se
coince
et que le système est en train vraiment
de de oui le se coincer comment peut-on
faire et quel serait les solutions que
vous pouvez proposer pour faire en sorte
que on reconstruit cette fois-ci non pas
un New Deal du mobile mais un good deal
de l'ensemble du numérique en France
merci Patrick Anne-Catherine Loisier
madame la Présidente merci
pour ces interventions et merci surtout
pour
effectivement pour le travail qui a été
réalisé par l'ensemble des opérateurs je
pense qu'il faut le dire c'est que la
France aujourd'hui quand même et bien
équipée et vous l'avez souligné à des
tarifs qui rentrent quand même
le service accessible à l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens alors moi je voudrais
juste revenir sur deux points d'abord
sur l'extinction du cuivre je pense que
l'ensemble de mes collègues participent
à ce mouvement aujourd'hui dans le cadre
des comités cuivre qui sont mis en place
sur nos territoires et dont nous pouvons
mesurer la complexité alors moi je suis
assez d'accord avec vous c'est que j'ai
un petit peu de mal à comprendre la
méthode d'orange puis qu'effectivement
là on a un territoire comme le mien il
commence d'abord par les zones rurales
qui sont finalement les moins les moins
équipés et avec une population d'un
public qui est peut-être le moins
accessible en tout cas voilà réceptif à
la démarche néanmoins c'est quand même
un sujet sur lequel
je pense qu'avec mes collègues nous
pensons qu'il faut quand même prendre un
le temps le temps de d'informer nos
concitoyens parce que là on a on a
potentiellement un sujet de grande
inquiétude et de grands angoisses donc
on va peut-être pas trop en rajouter en
ce moment
je voulais également vous poser quelques
questions sur votre stratégie spatiale
en fait puisque on évoquait tout à
l'heure votre le rachat de de Salt et
votre partenariat alors je sais pas
comment il faut l'appeler avec Starlink
pour les émissions sur les zones
blanches donc je voulais savoir où en
était ce partenariat combien d'abonnés
aujourd'hui en France et comment vous
appréhendez ce partenariat avec la
stratégie constellation européenne Iris
et puis une petite question sur le Cloud
souverain le Cloud de confiance
qu'elle est aujourd'hui la stratégie de
ce qu'elle web votre filiale dans le
cadre dans notamment des offres Cloud
puisque moi j'entends par exemple de
plus en plus
d'universités qui reçoivent des offres
Cloud gratuites de tous les grands
opérateurs américains des offres qui
sont quand même assez captives puisque
une fois que vous avez profité de
l'offre gratuite et bien après vous vous
avez beaucoup de mal à en ressortir donc
quel est votre stratégie sur mon avis
ces dossiers importants pour l'avenir
merci merci Anne-Catherine je vous
laisser réagir à déjà ce voilà j'ai un
paquet en télécom c'est ça
le sénateur sur le prix du cuivre et
votre point mais qui est le principal
utilisateur du découpage dans ce pays
orange
donc quand on monte les prix du
dégroupage quel est le seul qui jamais
touché c'est lui je vous le redis ça
je.fr ADSL 1999 fibre optique 29,99 et
ouais et quand on monte les prix du
dégroupage sache 1999 fibre optique
29,99 et donc on va pas monter nos prix
et qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et bien on
va faire du transfert financier vers
Orange et qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et
bien on va pousser orange de se dépêcher
de ne surtout pas éteindre le cuivre
parce que à partir de ce moment là
au pages à 20 euros hors taxes qui vont
vendre une offre à 19,99 TTC et que nous
on la prendra aussi à 19,4 TTC mais
pourquoi ils ne pourront pas mais pour
quelle raison il le vendent à 19 mais il
le vend déjà à perdre quand il le
vendent à 19,99 aujourd'hui vous faites
quelque chose là-dessus rien mais
personne ne fait rien sur le sujet on a
fait 20 ans de procédure là-dessus
orange a été condamné quoi quinze fois
en procédure concurrentielle mais ça
prend 10 ans ils seront condamnés dans
10 ans mais ça sera trop tard et donc le
sujet quand on augmente le prix du
dégroupage aujourd'hui on vous donne une
rampe de situation orange et des parts
de marché orange et bah c'est pour ça
qu'on est contre parce qu'on pense que
c'est une erreur par contre si on dit on
revient à cette question nous
augmenterons les prix du dégroupage le
jour où dans un an jour pour jour vous
allez fermer le réseau alors là tout le
monde va stresser y compris orange tout
le monde va se presser et c'est une
autre demande ah non c'est pas ça l'idée
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de dire
la zone fibrée c'est effectivement la
zone sur lequel la fibre est disponible
super et ben dans ce cas-là éteignant de
cuivre pourquoi on éteint pas le cuve à
cet endroit là
et ben on est d'accord on va on va
laisser monsieur Niels et donc pour nous
nous sommes ok pour une hausse du
dégroupage un an avant la fermeture
pratique du réseau et même que ça soit
des réguler c'est pas un sujet on voit
regarder les prix je vous rappelle qu'il
doit y aller des obligations
d'orientation mais il faut que ça soit
fait un an pas 5 ans avant et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on nous vend c'est 5
ans avec une harcèle complètement
acquise à Orange qui se couche devant
orange et c'est ça mon sujet et c'est ça
notre sujet aujourd'hui sur le New Deal
le l'objectif je vous l'ai dit c'est
pour chaque opérateur de déployer 5000
sites d'améliorer sa couverture de 5000
comment
couverture ciblée
de transport nous on est ravi on vient
de signer un contrat avec un grand
transporteur donc on doit s'améliorer de
la même manière mais on a je vous ai dit
1300 1300 sites on a ouvert 2306
excusez-moi tout à l'heure donc on
continue de le faire on continue de vous
voir faire je vous félicite de me faire
remarquer que l'État français
probablement perdu 3 milliards d'euros
de recettes mais par contre je vous ai
pas vu sur un vrai appel d'Off sur les
chaînes de télévision qui font des
profits supérieurs aux nôtres c'est pas
votre domaine mais c'est quand même des
fréquences et on est en concurrence sur
ces fréquences vous avez une chaîne de
télévision qui est M6 qui fait une marge
supérieure à celle d'elvmh et au bout ça
ne choque personne et on en parle pas de
facturer des fréquences et vous venez de
parler de facturation de fréquence alors
que dans le même temps vous nous
demandez des obligations de couverture
qu'on va jamais demander une chaîne de
télévision vous leur demandez rien ces
chaînes de télévision même pas de
produire suffisamment de fiction
c'est pas votre procès mes chiens à vous
dire vous me dites où vous nous avez
pris 3000 nous à la collectivité nous
avez pris 3 milliards d'euros de
recettes non on a fait un deal dans
lequel c'est 3 milliards d'euros de
recettes étaient échangé contre des
déploiements de site que nous n'aurions
pas fait et c'était ça un autre volonté
et c'est ce que nous avons mis en œuvre
et c'est ce que nous faisons mais dans
le même temps nous pensons qu'il est
saint et intéressant de regarder la
totalité des fréquences et que tout le
monde puisse se retrouver facturé la
stabilité de nos tarifs dans le mobile
alors attendez alors là moi je marche
sur la Smart là je marche sur la lune
vous êtes en train de me dire augmenter
vos prix alors là franchement mais elle
est devant la répression datation
nationale allez devant les Français vous
m'avez dit vous pratiquez des tarifs
extrêmement bas trop bas mais on est
tous attendez attendez je fais mon
métier attendez c'est moi qui dirige ici
les débats je vais baisser le volume
tout le monde se calme tout le monde se
calme voilà si vous souhaitez pas de
choix là je peux m'en aller et je vous
promets je suis venu ce matin
spontanément et gentiment j'ai pas de
problème à partager ça je vous dis juste
je vous en remercie vous venez
m'agresser vous venez m'agresser sur des
sujets précis excusez-moi de d'être
je vous conseille s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît c'est moi qui dirige ici
Monsieur Niel à la parole je lui demande
d'être peut-être un tout petit peu plus
calme parce que sinon on n'arrivera pas
à tenir la salle jusqu'au bout monsieur
chaise vous a posé des questions madame
moisi aussi réponds voilà vous avez le
droit à la parole de vous exprimer on a
le droit de vous écouter calmement donc
sur la stabilité de nos tarifs mobiles
je c'est un sujet encore une fois ou
quand on nous dit vous pratiquez les
tarifs trop peu cher je vous écoute je
vous prends le point moi je me vois
enfin encore une fois ça fait partie de
nos atouts ça fait partie de ce que l'on
apporte aux Français leur apporter du
pouvoir d'achat c'est-à-dire dans un
monde où tout le monde où tous les prix
montent où on va avoir des problèmes
incroyablement supérieurs à ceux que
l'on a en ce moment sur d'autres
réformes avec des hausses de prix
significatives qui peuvent atteindre 10
à 15%, qu'une société soit responsable
dans ce pays et disent je ne vais pas
augmenter mes prix me paraît pas quelque
chose
sur lequel on pourrait avoir des
remarques je pense qu'au contraire
ça devrait être vu comme quelque chose
de positif je crois que la question de
Monsieur chaise n'était pas vous devez
pas le faire la question était
estonenable pour vous c'était ça la
question il n'y avait pas d'accusation
derrière mais une question moi je suis
heureux d'être ici de vous faire pitié
ou de vous faire de la peine je vous en
remercie c'est assez rare
je vous en remercie ne faites pas dans
la dans la provocation monsieur niale on
n'est pas on n'est pas parti sur le bon
pied donc voilà donc notre sujet est-ce
que nous sommes une société responsable
est-ce que nous sommes une société
responsable qui sait compter oui nous
sommes une société responsable qui
savons côté donc on a un modèle
économique qui se tient on est un
opérateur rentable qui dégage du cash se
cache systématiquement
utiliser pour être
réinvesti dans nos réseaux donc on calme
nos réinvestissement dans en fonction de
nos générations de cash de nos capacités
à générer du cash je vous l'ai dit à la
fin il en reste pas beaucoup mais c'est
comme ça et on s'est créé où on a existé
on s'est développé en investissant dans
des réseaux en investissement de
l'argent et c'est notre choix et c'est
notre volonté d'investir sur le sujet du
plan de reprise le sujet c'est 200000
lignes un peu plus de 200000 lignes dans
lequel nous sommes mis d'accord sur une
procédure de raccordement renforcé et
une suivie et un suivi de près si ça ne
devait pas fonctionner on a pris
l'engagement de redéployer le réseau sur
ces
2000 prises sur le sujet du New Deal
c'est je vous ai répondu indirectement
sur le coup des fréquences le coût de
l'argent que l'on mettait dans ces
fréquences
l'argent que l'on va mettre et je pense
que tous ces trois sujets sont liés
l'argent que l'on va remettre dans ces
fréquences c'est de l'argent qu'on ne
remettra pas sur des couvertures de zone
où il pourrait y avoir besoin de
couverture mais encore une fois c'est un
choix c'est un choix je dis juste qu'en
2027 vous allez avoir des
un arrêt du déploiement des quatre
opérateurs de ces 5000 sites
si la couverture du territoire est
satisfaisante à ce moment-là pour
l'ensemble des populations il y a pas de
raison d'avoir un outil mais je suis pas
sûr qu'à ce moment-là vous n'ayez pas de
demande supplémentaires et s'il y a pas
de demande supplémentaire dans ce cas-là
oui bien évidemment il faut avoir un
appel d'offre parce que même pas les
opérateurs c'est d'avoir une incertitude
sur ces notions de fréquence c'est
toujours un stress une problématique
une non vision une non-connaissance du
coup est un
sujet sur
l'extinction du cuivre le sujet c'est de
ne pas avoir de transfert de valeur
entre les opérateurs c'est ça notre
principal sujet si on éteint le cuivre
et
à un moment lointain et que dans le même
temps on permet à des acteurs de
pratiquer les prix plus bas sur ces
zones en cuivre et ben on se retrouve
avec un sujet de transfert de valeur ou
de transfert parc d'abonnés entre les
entre les opérateurs et c'est un vrai
sujet sur Starlink c'est pas un deal que
nous avons en France c'est un accord que
nous avons en Suisse ce que ce que nous
avons fait nous avons donné du spectre
on a beaucoup de spectre en Suisse on a
donné une partie du spectre que nous
avons enfin on a pas donné on a permis à
Starling d'utiliser une partie du
spectre que nous avons ce qui permet
dans les zones non couvertes c'est des
zones on a une très bonne couverture en
Suisse mais ce qui permet dans les zones
montagnardes notamment d'avoir la
possibilité sans changer d'abonnement de
se connecter à
un opérateur
satellitaire c'est du bas des biens ça
remplace jamais ce qu'on est capable de
faire mais ça nous a paru
incroyablement
important de faire ça parce que on avait
des endroits où on avait des défauts de
couverture et ce surplus de spectre nous
permet de le faire c'est aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas ouvert commercialement c'est
intégré automatiquement pour la plupart
abonnés ce n'est pas ouvert
commercialement
ça va l'être
je sais pas si on est capable de faire
la même chose en France on a moins de
spectre c'est plus difficile mais on
pense que le satellite c'est un va
permettre de couvrir des zones
là où on arrivera pas à même et même en
fibre optique il y a les endroits vous
savez il y a et on pourra en reparler
tout à l'heure ce sera sur une partie
des raccordements finaux compliqués et
complexe je sais pas comment je crois
qu'ils ont peut-être une complexe c'est
à dire qu'il y a un moment si vous se
dire on va être capable de d'aller sur
un foyer dépenser 20 000 ou 30000 euros
pour une recette de 30 euros par mois il
y a toujours un sujet il y a un problème
de sujet et donc c'est comment on est
capable de traiter ce sujet là et puis
il y a des endroits où on va avoir 20 km
de déploiement 30 km de déploiement pour
un foyer et là je pense que le satellite
peut avoir un vrai sens dans ces dans
ces dans ces zones je sais pas si on le
fera avec Starling et je sais pas si
c'est on est légitime à revendre cette
offre-là là ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'on prend son mobile
ce sont les fréquences classiques on est
à un endroit où on n'a pas de couverture
avec le réseau traditionnel de Salt et
bien à cet endroit là où dans cet
endroit là on va voir la possibilité
d'accéder
à ça sur le Cloud soudain souverain
on a vu quelque chose d'assez
que moi je trouve personnellement
problématique c'est qu'on a dit ok on
veut du cloud souverain en France mais
en fait ce qu'on va faire on va
permettre d'avoir les logiciels
Américains et les déployer
sur des machines systems on va voir la
possibilité d'utiliser les logiciels
américains sur des machines qui seront
physiquement en France mais dans le
Cloud c'est pas les machines ou leur
localisation le problème c'est le
logiciel qui est utilisé et on a
beaucoup combattu le cette vision du
ministère de l'économie en disant si on
veut un club souverain il faut qu'il y
ait des gens qui fassent du logiciel
souvent et en fait c'est tout c'est
toute l'idée de de ce qu'elle ouest ça
reste une petite entreprise en fait une
centaine de milliers un peu plus de 100
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
on a une très forte croissance mais
c'est tout le sujet de ce de cette
entreprise ou c'est je sais pas 500 600
développeurs qui refont le soft de 0
pour faire du Cloud et donc et donc en
fait on travaille aujourd'hui c'est de
rattraper le retard en terme de de
produits que l'on peut avoir vis-à-vis
des Américains il y a un certain nombre
des Chinois il y a un certain nombre de
produits sur lesquels on est en avance
qu'ubernétise des choses comme ça des
petites briques sur lesquelles qui sont
des briques importantes sur lesquels
nous sommes en avance on les met en
oeuvre on travaille c'est des
investissements lourds on pense que
l'intelligence artificielle
c'est une vraie chance c'est des
investissements qu'on est en train de
faire en centaines de millions d'euros
d'achat d'équipements mais on est en
train de les faire parce qu'on pense que
c'est absolument
incontournable nécessaire
je sais pas comment on peut on peut
sur ces sujets d'intelligence
artificielle
ce truc est fou c'est que la plupart des
talents dans les entreprises américaines
qui font l'intelligence artificielle sur
français c'est à dire qu'on a c'est à
dire que collectivement on a financé des
études à des jeunes brillantissimes
qui vont créer des produits
exceptionnels mais au-delà de nos
frontières et donc on pense que ce sujet
d'intelligence artificielle mélangé au
Cloud parce que tout le monde va pas
intégrer des machines intelligence
artificielles dans son entreprise donc
on a une légitimité à revendre ses
services et à les développer mais donc
c'est un sujet d'investissement pour
nous cette année significatif je pense
je vous le redis en centaines de
millions d'euros pour être capable
d'avoir les équipements et les logiciels
ici en France permettant de
des tiers à d'autres personnes
publiques privées associatif d'être
capable de recréer des produits
équivalents à chaque
achète j'ai pété par exemple à Wall-E ou
à plein de produits d'intelligence
artificielle qui sont devenus maintenant
des produits grand public que tout le
monde peut utiliser mais quand vous
voyez que les sols les seuls produits
avancés sont
américains
chinois derrière et qu'on a rien de
visible ou proche en France alors qu'on
est en Europe alors qu'on beaucoup pour
le faire c'est un vrai sujet et c'est un
et c'est un élément extrêmement
important pour nous et un sujet
d'investissement selon l'argent dans 10
ans sur ces sujets là mais on pense
qu'on doit faire cet investissement là
parce que on n'a pas envie d'être
déclassé la création de Skyway elle
vient d'une volonté partagée de de des
salariés de d'Iliade et de Free qui qui
sont de dire est-ce que moi j'ai envie
que les données de mes enfants soit
stockés à terme à l'autre bout de la
terre avec des rails qui ne sont pas qui
ne sont pas nos règles alors elles
peuvent sembler obsolètes mais est-ce
qu'on a envie de ça et la réponse était
non et c'est sur la base de ça qu'on a
créé cette cette société et qu'on l'a
développé et dernier point et je m'en
excuse monsieur le sénateur de ma
passion pour les télécoms et donc de ma
voix trop élevée je ne commencerai je
recommencerai pas je vous présente
sincèrement mes excuses
apaiser les choses on est ici au Sénat
pas à l'Assemblée nationale alors je
vais prendre toute une série de
questions supplémentaires donc Alain
Cadec notre collègue breton et ensuite
Jean-Pierre Moga
alors c'est à vous détendre l'examine du
jour
merci madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur Niel
en 2022 votre groupe il y a de maisons
maires d'Internet Free et Free Mobile à
réaliser un chiffre d'affaires de 8,4
milliards d'euros
l'année a été marquée par une forte
croissance de ses activités en France
mais aussi en Pologne vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure avec la marque play
depuis 2020 et
UPC Polska depuis 2022 en Italie
également avec il y a l'Italia vous
revendiquez la place de sixième
opérateur européen avec près de 46
millions d'abonnés il semblerait que
vous ambitionniez de grimper au
troisième rang c'est votre objectif
semble-t-il en cherchant à investir dans
d'autres pays européens même au-delà
de l'Union européenne alors la question
c'est avez-vous des pistes précises sur
lesquels j'ai deux ou trois autres
questions toujours aussi sympa je vous
rassure
alors par ailleurs après avoir investi à
titre individuel dans le groupe le monde
donc vous êtes copropriétaire vous
rachetez le groupe Nice-Matin
France antique pareturf
vous avez pas un tuyau non
et vous portez acquéreur de la revue
L'Illustration
il s'agit d'ailleurs du premier
hebdomadaire illustré en France
créé en 1843
et reconnu
œuvre d'intérêt patrimonial majeur par
le ministère de la Culture alors
s'agissant de cette publication quelles
sont vos intentions concernant la ligne
éditoriale de ce magazine est-ce que
vous allez à la changer est-ce que vous
allez rester sur le même état d'esprit
et enfin j'ai deux autres questions
rapidement le 15 février dernier vous
avez présenté aux membres de l'arcom le
projet ambitieux de votre chaîne de télé
6 avec l'espoir de remplacer M6 sur le
cas d'un 6 de la TNT vous avez à cette
occasion reçu le soutien des syndicats
culturels notamment le Syndicat national
de l'édition phonographique SNP mais
finalement votre projet n'a pas été
retenu alors l'arcom vous a-t-elle donné
une raison
qui vous a semblé juste ou plausible
avec ce premier revirement allez vous
persévérer dans votre intention de créer
une chaîne de télé peut-être sur un
autre canal et si oui laquelle dernière
question vous avez en dehors des
télécommunications et de la presse
diversifiée vos activités dans un nombre
important de domaine dans lesquels vous
avez pris des parts notamment dans
l'éducation et la formation au métier du
net du numérique et de l'immobilier
avez-vous l'intention de poursuivre
cette diversification ou bien
souhaitez-vous vous recentrer sur les
secteurs essentiels de votre activité
voilà merci
beaucoup merci madame la Présidente moi
aussi monsieur le Président Directeur
Général je vais sortir de la guerre
entre la fibre et le et le cuivre et je
vais vous parler plus de sujets et de
réflexion que que vous avez
certainement et et que j'aimerais bien
que vous nous fassiez passer par par
exemple jugez-vous que la France agit
suffisamment pour garantir une sécurité
optimale de ces réseaux c'est quand même
un sujet je crois qu'il préoccupe tout
le monde et qu'en pensez-vous qu'elle
est aussi votre votre vision sur
l'utilisation extensive des réseaux
sociaux par les jeunes les Chinois ont
interdit Tik Tok je pense qu'en France
on interdira pas certaines choses
mais que pas que pensez-vous de ce sujet
juste sujet quand même de
société et puis nous sommes ici un
certain nombre à être allés visiter il y
a quelques temps l'école 42 que vous
avez créé l'école 42 est une école qui
est une école ouverte à tous qui est une
école qui est gratuite quel regard
portez-vous sur les besoins en formation
de la filière numérique et l'action de
l'État est-ce que vous considérez que
l'action de l'État est suffisante dans
ce domaine je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
Président je vais m'éloigner encore un
peu plus des sujets qui sont ce matin
passionnés j'ai déposé il y a quelques
temps une proposition de loi relative au
développement de la culture scientifique
je ne désespère pas que dans cette
maison on vienne enfin à la discuté
monsieur le Président il me semble
absolument nécessaire que nous
concitoyens soient formés au réflexe au
raisonnement mathématique au
fondamentaux des protocoles de recherche
face aux enjeux qui nous attendent
aujourd'hui et la liste n'est pas
exhaustive quand je vous aurais parlé de
réchauffement climatique de crise
sanitaire de nanotechnologie deux
questions monsieur le Président vous
êtes un créateur d'entreprise
technologique de communication la
culture scientifique pourrait-elle faire
partie de vos diversifications à
l'avenir et envisagez-vous dans ce cas
de développer cette culture grand public
grâce à vos titres de presse
merci Françoise je me suis trompé dans
l'ordonnancement Bernard buis d'abord et
ensuite Fabien gay merci président
monsieur le Président Free est
actuellement un itinéraire sur le réseau
Orange quelle planque quel avenir pour
Free conserver le partenariat historique
ou jouer la concurrence entre les
opérateurs qui ne partagent qui
pourraient se partager de nouveaux
réseaux et ma deuxième question pose sur
la question de garantie concernant le
passage au 100% en fibres et le gain
performance se fera sans est-ce que je
gagne performance se fera sans
dégradation pour les consommateurs dans
un contexte de numérisation
exponentielle des usages
merci Madame la président bonjour
monsieur Niel
j'aurais des centaines de questions mais
je vais essayer d'en de maintenir sur
sur une vous avez dit au départ
que la dérégulation est l'arrivée de
Free
avait permis de faire baisser les prix
etc un des domaines où la dérégulation
avait fonctionné moi je gagne un courant
politique
qui considère que les biens communs
doivent être gérés par le bien public je
pense que les questions énergétiques la
question spatiale parce qu'elle va avoir
des vrais domaines comme la question
télécommunication mais
je dois avouer autant sur l'énergie ça
ne fonctionne pas on le voit sur le
ferroviaire vous pouvez y revienne et
les Anglais en premier c'est vrai que
sur les télécommunications on peut avoir
le débat non mais pour le coup il y a eu
l'innovation vous avez cassé les prix
vous en avez fait partie free à
bousculer les trois plus gros on se
refait pas l'histoire mais je pense
qu'on peut au moins se mettre d'accord
sur une chose vous et moi c'est que ça
c'est fait au détriment de choses
d'abord de l'emploi et des salariés il y
a une casse tout le monde sait ce qui
s'est passé à France Télécom et il y a
une question de sous-traitance
aujourd'hui et deuxièmement le privé et
c'est bien normal parce qu'il est là
pour faire la rentabilité c'est pas moi
qui dirait le contraire il s'est occupé
d'abord de là où c'était rentable et
donc il existe quand même encore
quelques zones blanches et pour le coup
je pense que là ça ne peut pas être
comme dans tous les autres domaines où
le privé va là où c'est rentable et
qu'on laisse ou semi-publique c'est plus
complexe que ça aujourd'hui tout ce qui
n'est pas rentable et donc les zones
désertées je pense qu'au moins on peut
se mettre d'accord sur ça et donc j'ai
une question précise je suis pas je suis
pas chez vous je suis désolé je suis pas
à Free je suis un nouveau concurrent
j'ai installé la fibre juste après le
confinement et je l'ai expliqué très
bien à votre collègue d'orange
j'ai été assez stupéfait que ça soit des
sous-traitants en cascades qui viennent
me l'installer et donc ça c'est une
question
vous avez vous êtes un grand chef
d'entreprise et il y a une
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale et sur la question de
l'emploi et la question la
sous-traitance notamment sur
l'installation de la fibre bon pose
question socialement mais pose question
aussi à des élus que nous sommes et le
western je le dis comme ça des
branchements ou les arrachages sont
légion la sous-traitance fait que comme
on est payé quasi à la pièce il faut
aller au vite et là c'est ni free je
pourrais pas free tout le monde est
pareil tout le monde arrive arrache se
branche et repart et donc là je pense
que nous en tant que législateur il faut
les giférer sur ça parce que si vous
appelez à ce qu'on aille encore plus
vite sur la question la firme il faut
encadrer son développement parce que là
il y a une véritable question moi la
dernière année je finis par là pendant
sur les 12 derniers mois je n'ai pas eu
la télé et internet et le téléphone
pendant trois mois à chaque fois trois
fois ça a été des arrachages quand je
dis moi c'est tout le quartier c'est pas
moi personnel et puis bon ben un autre
jour je vous pose sur plein d'autres
questions je suis très intéressé par la
presse mais je suis imagine que ton
collègue vous poseront d'autres
questions je vous remercie l'humain a
besoin d'un peu de coup d'un peu
d'argent là en ce moment très bien
merci Fabien Dominique Estrosi ça sonne
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président bonjour moi deux questions
l'une sur la cybersécurité les
collectivités territoriales sont de plus
en plus victimes d'attaque que
informatique ainsi que les PME des TPE
alors que les grands groupes eux
disposent généralement d'offres qui sont
adaptées à leurs besoins ou de logiciels
le groupe Iliade semble vouloir se
positionner sur ce secteur vous l'avez
dit dans vos propos liminaires alors que
Free c'est principalement concentré sur
le grand public jusqu'en 2020 sans
percer le marché des entreprises ni des
collectivités territoriales alors quel
serait le calendrier le périmètre des
offres il est tendu du dispositif de
cybersécurité j'avais posé une question
similaire à la PDG d'Orange lorsque nous
n'avons auditionné et elle nous avait
annoncé un investissement pour son
groupe de l'ordre de 1 milliard d'euros
dans le programme orange cyberdéfense
pour l'ensemble de ses clients et puis
sur le renouvellement des terminaux
simplement au regard des enjeux de
recyclage des terminaux en circulation
quelle politique commerciale met en
oeuvre Free pour le recyclage ou le
reconditionnement alors que le nombre de
vos points de vente reste relativement
modestes comparé comparativement à des
opérateurs qui sont plus anciens et qui
sont mieux implantés sous forme d'un
réseau de points de vente merci
merci beaucoup Dominique Daniel salmon
merci madame la Présidente
vous n'êtes pas sans connaître les
impacts négatifs du numérique sur la
santé mentale et même physique des
Françaises et des Français et en
particulier
des plus jeunes les études là comme
ailleurs s'accumulent pour nous montrer
que nous allons vers une catastrophe
annoncée je voudrais savoir comment vous
prenez en compte ces impacts du
numérique dans votre responsable
d'habilité sociale élargie et comment
vous allez pouvoir combiner ça avec
votre souhait de faire toujours plus de
volume puisque vous nous avez dit plus
c'est plein plus et rentabilisé et votre
objectif est bien de faire du cash comme
vous nous l'avez répété donc j'aimerais
savoir quels sont vos actions qu'est-ce
que vous allez mener dans l'avenir pour
éviter que nous allions vers cette
catastrophe merci
Noël ensuite Daniel grimillet puis
Florence delatrix contraire oui merci
Madame la présente monsieur le Président
alors que vous avez participé à sa
création en 2007 j'aurais souhaité
savoir pourquoi le groupe Free ne fait
pas partie de la Fédération Française
des Télécoms contrairement à votre
oiseau concurrents la FFT est en effet
un interlocuteur de qualité avec les
pouvoirs publics sur les questions de
numérique et de téléphonie il paraît
surprenant qu'à un groupe comme le vôtre
n'en fasse pas partie et puis ma
deuxième question a déjà été abordée par
Fabien gay je souhaiterais savoir ce que
votre groupe envisage de mettre en
oeuvre pour mieux contrôler la qualité
du travail des sous-traitants au moment
du raccordement des
usagers je vous remercie merci Sylviane
Daniel Gremillet
je vais pas vous parler de culture mais
d'agriculture parce qu'en fait vous avez
investi dans un centre de formation dans
un incubateur
[Musique]
hectare notamment vous êtes
vous travaillez beaucoup dans la
recherche développement sur la robotique
sur la ferme verticale
[Musique]
quelles sont ces raisons c'est une
nouvelle vision de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup et Florence blatrix
compta
là tu veux pas venir par ici merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président donc je voilà avec plusieurs
collègues dans le cadre de la délégation
aux entreprises nous travaillons sur une
mission compétence attractivité emploi
et nous avons d'ailleurs ce matin
échangé avec Thierry Marx sur ce voilà
tout est initiatives qu'il a eu en
matière de formation basée sur le projet
d'individu donc avec l'école 42 pour
rejoindre un peu la question de mon
collègue
de mon collègue qu'est-ce que pourquoi
ce projet et qu'est-ce que quelle est la
complémentarité avec les formations
existantes et en quoi est-ce qu'on sur
quelles compétences
allez-vous supplémentaire allez-vous
aller dans le domaine du numérique et
justement vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le voilà la main d'oeuvre qui
allait aux États-Unis qui ne restait pas
en France pour des besoins que l'on a
ici donc comment faire pour retrouver
une attractivité garder cette main d'or
qu'on a formé en France très bien merci
Florence et dernière question d'Amel
voilà un petit merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président une
question sur un sujet que nous n'avons
pas je pense précisément abordé c'est un
impact des réseaux de télécommunications
sur les missions des gaz à effet de
serre aujourd'hui c'est un vrai sujet un
rapport récent d'ailleurs du Sénat a
évoqué je crois une augmentation de plus
de 60% si on ne fait rien de
consommation de gaz à effet de serre
d'ici 2040 notamment via les usages la
production de terminaux je sais que vous
êtes déjà engagé dans ce sens mais
est-ce qu'il est prévu aujourd'hui une
accélération justement où des
investissements ou d'un plan en tout cas
qui pourrait aller dans ce sens merci
merci à vous pour toutes ces questions
monsieur Niel je vous laissez évidemment
répondre vous disant tout le monde
attachement à la question de Daniel
grimmiller puisque c'est installé dans
les Yvelines donc j'ai très voilà à
l'aimer ça donc je suis très curieuse de
savoir ce qui s'y passe et la vision
qu'il y a derrière cela évidemment
alors sur nos activités nos déploiement
ou notre développement dans les dans les
télécommunications
d'autres sujets c'est de se dire on a un
savoir-faire appris en France grâce à la
concurrence qui a pu exister en France
et comment on est capable d'utiliser
savoir-faire dans d'autres pays sur
d'autres territoires pour créer de la
valeur et de la croissance donc
aujourd'hui je voulais dire on est dans
une vingtaine de pays on est un
actionnaire très minoritaire de la
société Vodafone et on a 20% d'une d'un
groupe sud-américain qui s'appelle
milicom
et qui est présent dans 7 pays en
Amérique du Sud donc on continue ce
travail de déploiement ni historiquement
on est actionnaire d'une société de
fibre optique à Singapour mais on a
toujours essayé d'utiliser notre
savoir-faire pour aider des entreprises
à se développer
et accroître et puis on a la volonté de
continuer de le de le faire
et on apporte en ayant toujours des
équipes en France pour un certain nombre
de dans ces pays on a créé des sites en
France de sous-traitance de gestion des
réseaux de développement des systèmes
d'information et c'est des peut-être un
millier d'emplois qui sont créés en
France pour aider nos activités
en dehors de France et on continue de le
faire parce qu'on pense qu'on a un vrai
savoir-faire des gens qui ont reçu une
forme de personnes qui ont reçu une
formation en France incroyablement
performante pour avancer pour nous aider
à nous développer sur ces territoires et
donc on le fait et on avance sur le sur
la presse le l'illustration et l'un des
plus anciens magazines ayant existé vous
avez cité qui a été créé je crois en
en fait il y avait toutes les archives
qui étaient là et on a repris ces
archives avec la volonté de les rendre
plus accessibles plus disponibles c'est
c'est des archives incroyables c'est des
centaines de milliers de de pièces donc
on a cette volonté de continuer
le travail qui est faite sur le travail
patrimonial il est fait dessus c'est une
vocation non non commerciale mais
d'aider à
les mettre en avant à les faire
connaître à mieux les faire connaître et
peut-être les utiliser dans nos autres
activités
de sur le projet de 6
nous a pas donné de raison pour
lesquelles nous n'avons pas été
reçu
on l'a dit un publiquement on avait
l'impression d'une procédure
perdue d'avance on nous l'avait pas dit
comme ça parce que les gens sont polis
mais on nous l'a fait comprendre mais on
espère avoir réussi à apporter
ou à aider les sociétés d'auteurs
d'une manière générale à avoir ou à
bénéficier de plus d'investissement des
chaînes existantes
parce que ces chaînes je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure utilisent du spectre un
bien commun et génère dessus des revenus
des revenus et des marges significatives
et on pense que les obligations qui
devraient être en face devraient être
plus initiative donc on y est avec la
volonté de gagner nous avons perdu mais
dans le même temps on souhaitait faire
ça avec les le globalement toute la
création tout le monde de la création je
ne sais pas si nous reviendrons sur ces
sujets on pense que l'on peut exister
que dans le monde de la télévision que
si on a un des six premiers canaux parce
que ce sont ceux qui sont vus qui sont
connus qui sont notoires et que les
autres les accompagnent et donc on avait
dit publiquement que si nous n'avions
pas ce canal 6 on était pas vraiment
intéressés par les autres canaux alors
sur l'éducation et 42 alors il y a
plusieurs questions je sais pas si je
vais réussir à toutes les regrouper mais
et j'espère répondre à tout l'idée de 42
c'était ça partait d'un constat qui
était
assez simple c'était de se dire les
formations
au Digital ou numérique sont nombreux en
France elles sont qualités mais
malheureusement elles sont souvent
privées et chères c'est-à-dire que ce
sont des écoles plutôt bonnes qui
apprennent le code informatique mais
dans la scolarité coûte une dizaine de
milliers d'euros par an et donc on est
accessible qu'à quelques pourcents des
Français et l'idée était dire est-ce
qu'on est capable de créer la meilleure
école où on va apprendre le code
informatique qui soit gratuit et ouverte
à tous et c'est ce que l'on a fait avec
42 avec une première école qui apparaît
dans le 17ème arrondissement qui est un
peu un petit peu moins de 4000 élèves
aujourd'hui avec des méthodes
d'enseignement différentes qui
permettent de s'adapter
à des jeunes qui sont des décrochés
scolaires donc il y a pas de cours
formelle on apprend ensemble c'est un
lieu physique c'était pas du c'est pas
une du télé- apprentissage c'est un lieu
physique dans lequel on apprend ensemble
et c'est un énorme succès puisque les
jeunes qui sortent de cette école ont
tous des salaires significatifs autour
de 40000 euros le 40%
on avait un défaut c'était une école qui
manquait de de diversité
notamment en termes de de public de
d'élèves de femmes élèves de jeunes
femmes élèves de femmes et jeunes femmes
élèves maintenant l'école est dirigés
par une femme donc ça a permis de monter
entre 30 et 40% le nombre de femmes
présentes dans l'école on c'est une
initiative qui a 10 ans c'est une
initiative qui marche puisque c'est ces
écoles on en a plusieurs enfants
aujourd'hui
on en a une petite cinquantaine dans le
monde je crois 47 48 ça continue de se
développer cette année de ne pas y en
avoir une vingtaine qui vont ouvrir dans
le monde c'est un peu moins de 20 000
élèves dans le monde qui aujourd'hui
apprennent avec cette pédagogie
différente sont formées
toujours ce sont toujours sites
systématiquement des écoles gratuites
et c'est environ une scolarité qui dure
trois ans et dont l'entrée est basée sur
des choses qui sont des critères
qui permettent d'accepter tout le monde
en fait c'est ces deux éléments un
premier élément c'est ce qu'on est
logique et ça c'est vraiment l'ADN de
nos parents et ce qu'ils ont eu la
gentillesse de nous donner cette cette
chance d'être logique et puis la
deuxième deuxième critère c'est est-ce
que j'ai envie de faire cette école
est-ce que j'ai envie de bosser et
d'apprendre et ce sont les deux seuls
critères les deux seules choses que l'on
demande
à nos à nos élèves on a avancé parce
qu'au début on a qu'à les principalement
des gens jeunes et en travaillant avec
avec Pôle Emploi on accepte maintenant
des des personnes qui ont une
soixantaine d'années qui ont travaillé
dans l'informatique ont été formés de
manière un peu ancienne et probablement
obsolète et quand on les reprend qui
sont des gens que généralement dont on
pense qu'il est le retour au travail est
impossible et on voit que ça marche et
donc on continue de développer des
pleins d'initiatives en essayant de se
dire comment on est capable avec cette
école d'apporter ou de permettre à tout
le monde d'avoir
un métier c'est c'est monoformation pas
parfait on peut trouver plein de
reproches à faire à cette école mais
c'est monoformation en garanti un job et
un job bien payé et un job d'avenir et
donc on essaie toujours de réfléchir
pour l'améliorer
et le rêve des équipes c'est bien sûr
d'en avoir toujours plus parce que on a
un système qui marche partout vous en
avez encore et vous en avez au Japon
vous en avez deux au Brésil vous en avez
deux au Maroc vous en avez une qui va
ouvrir dans les jours qui viennent en
Mangola RDC veut en faire une il y en a
une à Dakar qui a ouverte ou qui va
ouvrir enfin on est partout dans le
monde et ça marche partout donc c'est un
mode de un mode de fonctionnement qui
est là et qui fait fonctionner la
censeur social moi je suis toujours
super tellement déprimé de voir qu'on
est en dernière position de CV en termes
d'ascenseur social c'est-à-dire que si
vos parents étaient ouvriers votre
chance de ne pas être ouvrier ça
n'existe pas et pourtant on est un pays
où on a le sentiment que c'est
complètement différent et moi j'ai eu
cette chance j'ai eu cette chance de
de montrer au reste du monde que la
France est un pays d'entrepreneurs ça
marche incroyablement ça se développe ça
fonctionne c'est un lieu de visite pour
les chefs d'État étrangers qui viennent
en France et je pense que c'est quelque
chose de
pousser des jeunes à aller vers ça c'est
de leur garantir un job et c'était un
peu pareil sur sur hectare l'idée
c'était de se dire
est-ce que la est-ce que le les
agriculteurs c'est des des petits
entrepreneurs souvent il y a des grands
entrepreneurs dans l'agriculture mais il
y a souvent des petits entrepreneurs et
comment on est capable de former des
jeunes
urbains il y a une notion chez nous chez
les personnes qui ont une vingtaine
d'années de quête de sens et la quête de
sens elle peut passer par l'alimentation
et la production de de son alimentation
et donc comment on est capable de former
des jeunes
urbains ou pas urbains assez nouveaux
métiers
de l'agriculture leur apprendre des
techniques différentes leur apprendre à
faire
les choses
différemment et donc l'idée c'est de
créer un lieu un lieu significatif grand
en région parisienne parce que c'est ma
région il y a pas du parisianisme
volontaire mais c'est là où j'habite et
c'est là où je vis où c'est là où j'ai
grandi mais comment on est capable
un endroit physique donné d'apprendre
d'autres formes d'apprentissage alors
comme j'ai investi parfois dans des
startups de viande particulière ou des
choses comme ça on a supposé que j'avais
une vision de l'agriculture c'est un
directement votre question je crois
j'avais une vision de l'agriculture
problématique vous pouvez problématique
pardon différentes je mange de la viande
j'essaie d'en manger moins mais je mange
toujours de la viande
je me suis battu pour essayer de dire
sur la cause animale on pouvait essayer
de de ne pas faire souffrir les animaux
qu'on allait manger ça me paraît quelque
chose que l'on peut partager mais ça a
été interprété parfois mal et
différemment mais donc il y a toutes
toutes les initiatives que l'on vient de
parler sont des initiatives non
financières détenus par des associations
des fondations avec cette volonté
de d'aider d'aider mon pays parce que
parce que je l'aime beaucoup parce que
je l'aime beaucoup trop peut-être
parfois et que j'ai envie qu'il soit et
j'ai envie de de rendre ce qui m'a
permis de faire parce que je sais pas
s'il y a beaucoup de pays dans lequel
les choses qui me sont arrivées soient
possibles donc ça a été possible pour
moi ce n'est pas fait ce n'est pas ça
n'est pas assez de manière massive mais
envie d'aider dans ce sens-là sur mon
avis sur les sur le l'action de l'État
dans l'enseignement l'idée c'est que 42
ne dépendent absolument ni aucune des
initiatives ne dépendent aucunement de
l'État ou d’argent
d'argent public
rien n'est parfait
et non plus en termes d'éducation mais
ce que je vois encore une fois en forme
des mathématiciens fantastiques des
chercheurs très très bons dans
l'intelligence artificielle et que j'ai
arrêté mes études à 17 ans mais que la
formation que j'ai j'ai reçu à l'École
publique et à la fin de la scolarité
dans une école privée m'ont permis de me
forger ou de faire ce que je suis
aujourd'hui donc je vais pas cracher ou
j'ai pas envie de cracher dans la dans
la soupe voilà sur la sécurité des
réseaux je trouve qu'on a des un certain
nombre de services en France qui
travaillent très très bien et à chaque
fois qu'on a des problèmes dans le SI et
d'autres à chaque fois qu'on a des
sujets ils sont présents immédiatement
ils viennent voir ils creusent ils
trouvent les problèmes
c'est pas toujours vu comme ça mais nos
services nos différents services qui
travaillent sur ces sujets de sécurité
informatique sont vraiment incroyables
et quand on compare ça avec les autres
pays où nous faisons des télécoms il y a
une vraie différence positive pour
pour le pour la France sur le sur les
réseaux sociaux sur les jeunes
j'ai un avis pour mes propres enfants
qui je pensais partager par beaucoup
d'entre vous après si vous leur
interdisez les réseaux sociaux ils ont
l'impression de d'être exclus de groupe
par rapport à leur genre ne colle
l'excellaire donc c'est un sujet mais je
ne sais pas apporter une réponse
qui a un intérêt censé sur ce sujet
malheureusement en tant qu'opérateur on
met bien évidemment en place tout ce qui
nous est demandé par l'ensemble des des
régulateurs et organisation
ça me paraît le le strict minimum sur le
développement de la culture scientifique
oui moi je suis toujours très j'ai été
très inquiet par l'arrêt des
mathématiques c'est pas que j'aime
spécifiquement les mathématiques mais je
l'arrêt des mathématiques trop tôt dans
la scolarité et les choses qui sont
remises en oeuvre maintenant me
paraissent aller dans le bon sens sur
l'itinéant sur le réseau d'Orange on
utilise de la 2G ou de la fausse 3G
aujourd'hui sur le réseau d'Orange l'idé
et de ne pas redéployer un nouveau
réseau de de géants France on avait
commencé à redéployer un réseau de G
parce qu'on a un petit pourcentage de
nos abonnés qui n'ont aujourd'hui que
des terminaux de G donc on avait
commencé à déployer un réseau de G on
s'est mis d'accord avec Orange pour
utiliser leur réseau de G a priori
jusqu'à 2025 voilà ce qui nous permet
d'éviter de redéployer
un réseau sur la garantie du 100%
fibre donc tout est donc signé je crois
la totalité des rips qui peuvent exister
dans ce pays à l'exception de deux j'ai
le souvenir du tarin parce que je suis
originaire du Tarn et d'un autre
et Ariège donc je m'en excuse mais avec
qui nous avons des discussions et nous
espérons signer avec
un moment ou à un autre et puis à côté
de ça bien évidemment sur toutes les
initiatives nous souhaitons être
présents je sais pas si on arrivera du
100% fibre on arrivera probablement du
99 quelque chose pour s'en fibre et à la
fin avec une des formes de de
subventionnement d'argent public de
péréquation je ne sais pas quoi mais il
faudra mettre en place quelque chose si
on veut aller à ce niveau
là sur le sur les sur les les termine
sur le sur le déploiement des
des réseaux
nous on a 3000 salariés en interne qui
sont qui sont des salariés qui déploient
les les réseaux et les la partie finale
de de nos installations d'une manière
générale
réseau fibre excusez-moi pardon et des
réseaux fibres d'une manière générale on
a toujours cherché à internaliser au
maximum ce qui est la raison pour
laquelle on est le deuxième l'employeur
du secteur alors qu'en termes de chiffre
d'affaires on doit être plutôt le
troisième ou le 4e mais parce qu'on a
toujours significativement cherché à
internaliser c'est c'est déploiement et
quand nous vous en appel à des
sous-traitants d'une manière générale et
il peut y avoir des exceptions mais
d'une manière générale ce sont des
grandes entreprises et on s'interdit
d'avoir plus d'un niveau sous-traitant
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas avoir des
sous-traitants qui font de la
sous-traitance c'était des choses qui
ont été demandées que l'on met en oeuvre
à côté de ça on a mis en pratique un
certain nombre de choses notamment des
prises de photos avant après des choses
comme ça on a le droit d'espérer qu'il y
a des endroits que ça va que ça va
s'améliorer on a des problèmes précis
93-95 qui sont identifiés donc on a un
certain nombre de
de
sujets et on essaye de les traiter c'est
pas parfait je suis d'accord avec vous
maintenant c'est un nouveau les réseaux
c'est un réseau qui se déploie
rapidement mais c'est un réseau d'avenir
et donc tous les opérateurs n'ont pas
une vision long thermiste et
malheureusement parfois on peut avoir
dans certains cas des des visions
courtes et non pas le la préservation
d'un réseau pour les pour les 25 les 50
ou les 50 tous les 100 ans que on va
utiliser ce
ce
réseau et tout ça est mis en oeuvre dans
des discussions notamment avec l'ARCEP
sur le sur les télécommunications
professionnelles on a racheté une
société qui s'appelle Jaga Jaguar
network
c'est la volonté d'aller dans ce dans ce
secteur d'activité c'est un secteur très
peu concurrentiel
dominé par par un acteur historique qui
produit un service de qualité et donc la
volonté c'est d'amener un peu de
concurrence à cet endroit et dans le
même temps d'ajouter des des offres
permettant de régler les les problèmes
de cybers sécurité
et nombreux autres sujets mais c'est
quelque chose que font tous les acteurs
dans ce sens on n'est pas spécifiquement
en pointe sur la cybersécurité on fait
notre boulot comme les autres
contrairement à l'intelligence
artificielle sur lesquelles on met plus
de moyens vous avez évoqué le sujet du
renouvellement
déterminant c'est un sujet important
pour nous on s'est toujours battu contre
le la subvention des terminaux et la
cour d'attestation sur ce sujet nous a
rendu raison on pense que la subvention
déterminaux avec un abonnement
téléphonique pousse un renouvellement
trop trop rapide de ces terminaux un
terminal mobile et destiné à vivre plus
de 24 mois et donc c'est dommage que
quand votre opérateur vous appelle au
bout de 22 mois en vous disant écoute
pour très engager 24 mois je te donne un
nouveau terminal pour un euro et donc on
se bat depuis longtemps sur ce sujet là
on pense que c'est un sujet de
responsabilité de responsabilité de
responsabilisation et nous ne mettons
pas cela en œuvre nous ils ont déterminé
au travers de de de de terminaux ou de
de crédit ou de location avec option
d'achat pour tout le monde puisse y
accéder mais sans mélanger à la fois le
terminal avec
le le
l'abonnement sur le l'impact du
numérique sur la
santé mentale alors vous avez vous avez
dit que le le nous étions motivés par
remplir nos réseaux parce que plus nous
remplissions nos réseaux plus nous
gagnons d'argent nos réseaux ont un coût
fixe donc au contraire plus on remplit
nos réseaux plus on est obligé de
rajouter des antennes et de déployer du
réseau donc on n'a pas un intérêt à
avoir une surconsommation des abonnés
maintenant ils en ont ils font ce qu'ils
veulent et c'est leur liberté on leur
vend des forfaits ils les utilisent et
ils le font sur l'impact du numérique
sur la santé mentale je crois qu'on
participe
regarder tu me tu vas pas m'aider je
sens OK
[Musique]
d'associations ce qui nous empêche pas
de travailler avec elle avec les
syndicats
sur
je sais pas quoi je vous ai pas répondu
si pardon sur les réseaux télécoms et
leur impact sur les effets de serre
c'est des sujets incroyablesment
important pour nous
et sur lesquels on travaille on a
inventé des trucs on inventé des choses
on a créé des choses fantastiques et
qui ont un impact direct alors c'est pas
toujours vu à l'extérieur moi il y en a
un que j'aime bien et puis après on peut
vous envoyer on a plein d'éléments sur
le sujet on
investit nous-mêmes dans des dans des
nouvelles sources d'énergie dans des
avec notamment engie pour créer ensemble
des nouvelles des nouvelles productions
d'énergie non polluantes on travaille
beaucoup là-dessus mais sur une des
initiatives qu'on a mis en place il y a
quelques années qui est incroyable et
qui est que du bon sens
théoriquement quand vous rentrez dans
une salle de datacenter c'est l'endroit
où on met nos machines vous avez
toujours froid et donc on climatise du
vide c'est à dire qu'en fait on
climatique une énorme salle alors qu'il
y a que 10% de la salle qui est utilisé
pour mettre des machines meuf en fait ce
qu'on a inventé c'est qu'on a dit mais
on va arrêter climatiser c'est ça on va
climatiser que les machines et en fait
ça crée des choses où vous êtes dans des
salles où il fait 40 degrés partout sauf
à l'intérieur des machines puisque on va
créer des on appelle ça des cols
corridor excusez-moi pour le nom anglais
mais on va créer des couloirs dans
lequel on va souffler la clim ça va
passer dans les machines et ça va
réchauffer le reste de la de la pièce et
on gagne 30% de consommation d'énergie
en faisant ça et donc avec plein de
petits sujets comme ça on arrive à
s'améliorer on crée des nouvelles
générations de boxe dans nos nouvelles
générations de boxe on invente des trucs
des choses pour essayer de avec de
l'intelligence artificielle pour réussir
à faire baisser la consommation à un
moment que vous avez pas besoin de votre
Box vous avez pas besoin de ceci pas
besoin de cela c'est plein de petites
initiatives c'est des de choses qui au
bout font des rivières c'est long c'est
complexe c'est cher potentiellement mais
on le fait on les met en oeuvre et c'est
et il y a un truc il y a vraiment un
élément qui faut qu'il faut comprendre
c'est une vraie passion pour les équipes
c'est quel c'est-à-dire que les équipes
se sentent incroyablesment concernés et
je pense que c'est le cas chez tous les
opérateurs mais à chaque fois vont dire
non mais ça on peut pas faire ça c'est
c'est tel impact tel impact tel impact
tel impact on ne peut pas faire ça donc
on reprend la copie on est obligé de
rebosser et le sujet la pression elle
est interne mais avec une force
incroyable et c'est la chance d'être une
entreprise jeune on a je sais pas quel
est l'âge moyen des salariés chez Free
et je pense qu'elle est inférieur à 30
ans mais le fait d'avoir globalement des
salariés jeunes permet
il y a un côté volontaire pousse il
pousse à signifier à chaque fois que
l'on pense à ce à ce sujet emprunte
et globalement le monde que l'on va
laisser à nos enfants et et ça ça a été
un changement au cours des cinq
dernières années et on le voit je vous
dis on est sur une création de la
génération d'une nouvelle box et les
équipes dit non on peut pas faire ça
ouais mais attendez c'est c'est
significatif non on ne peut pas faire ça
parce que l'impact est négatif et donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
devenu pour les télécoms en tout cas
chez Free mais je pense que c'est la
même chose chez les autres opérateurs
quelque chose de central dans notre dans
notre travail quotidien
très bien merci beaucoup j'avais
peut-être une dernière petite question
quand on a fait un rapport sur la
souveraineté numérique avec amalgaquer
avec Franck montoget on est venu à
parler de la fiscalité d'utilisation des
réseaux notamment éventuellement d'une
fiscalité des gafams en particulier qui
prennent beaucoup de pente passante sur
les réseaux c'est un sujet qui est pas
un sujet français qui est un sujet
européen mais peut-être vous qui nous
avez parlé de fiscalité tout à l'heure
et diffère mobile est-ce que vous avez
un avis sur cela
si d'une manière ou d'une autre les
gafam sont capables de prendre en charge
une partie des investissements qui sont
faits pour pour eux on va pas être
contre je si vous nous remplacer l'hyper
par une taxe sur les Gafa femme
si vous êtes d'accord
quoi qu'est-ce qui coince aujourd'hui
vous qui êtes dans les arcanes je suis
pas sûr d'être plus que vous dans les
arcades j'espère pas d'ailleurs sinon il
y a un certain nombre de sujets de
problèmes mais non non
c'est un sujet compliqué puisque les
gafams vont vous dire
on a un sujet de de réseau ouvert de
liberté et si vous commencez à mettre un
pH et bien vous n'allez pas permettre
l'existence même d'Internet puisque
l'Internet est basé sur des réseaux qui
sont interconnectés plus ou moins
gratuitement
ce en quoi ils n'ont pas tort mais dans
le même temps les gafams représentent je
sais pas 65 ou enfin cinq acteurs parce
que on peut peut-être ajouter un N à
côté de gafam 5 ou 6 acteurs consomment
75 ou 80% d'autres bande passante donc
pour les 20 autres % il est légitime que
ce réseau que les réseaux soient ouverts
gratuits échangé
pour d'autres qui tire des revenus
significatifs des réseaux et qui
représentent surtout une parc
significative de la consommation sur ces
réseaux c'est une autre c'est un autre
sujet un autre problème nous aurons un
allié alors
je sais pas si notre poids pesera quel
contrôle manière merci d'y croire
très bien mais écoutez je vous remercie
infiniment j'ai compris qu'on avait un
sujet d'énervement général autour de des
groupages et de la fin du cuivre
et son point de vue donc merci beaucoup
en tout cas d'avoir accepté cette
audition et merci d'y répondre que vous
nous avez faites merci infiniment merci
chers collègues et je vous souhaite une
bonne journée et un bon anniversaire à
Patrick chaise lors d'une deuxième fois